millions of us shelter at home -
pandemic other Americans remain on
foreign shores still hoping to return
here cancelled flights sudden travel
restrictions and strict quarantines have
all blocked many people from getting
back and this week the State Department
warned that time may be running out Kris
Van Cleave has the story little grace
brought Michael and Whitney Savile to
India in early March they've been
working to adopt the toddler for two
years but we never anticipated them
keeping us from going home by the time
they navigated the adoption red tape
India was on lockdown back in Georgia
their three young sons staying with
family more than 38,000 Americans have
gotten home 240 arrived in Miami
Thursday from Ecuador on a charter
flight arranged by the State Department
Immigration and Customs Enforcement is
using its planes to bring back hundreds
more American Delta Eastern Spirit and
United have all added flights and
special charters carrying at least
17,000 and Counting president Trump
praised the State Department's efforts
you probably read about the young people
in Peru and young people in Brazil and
they were absolutely stuck and we got
him out got him almost everybody is out
now back home but at least 22,000
Americans still have not made it back
join McBrain and Ella Ponte a are stuck
in remote parts of Peru they couldn't
get out before the country closed its
borders you really have no idea how long
he'll be there
I've no idea how long I could be here
for Mitt Breen's hoping her ride comes
next week I'm worried if I were to get
sick with co19
at this point and so I literally haven't
been able to be outside this this home
woman's 17 days Ponte a got to Peru in
February to teach English I'm relying on
my government relying on the Peruvian
government
for them to cooperate and I have zero
say and what's to happen is very
frustrating and scary oh we got
everybody home that we can get him Ian
Brownlee is leading the State
Department's effort to get Americans
home which included sending boats up the
Amazon to pick people up was there a
plan what to do in a global emergency to
bring people back I will confess the
thought that we would have to run
evacuations from every region of the
world simultaneously was not something
we had gamed out who were rising to the
challenge we're doing it can you promise
every American who is overseas that
wants to come back that they will have
the ability to get back I will promise
every American who's overseas who comes
forward in a timely fashion while we are
still running these operations that we
will do everything we can to get them on
one of these planes
after a month in India Michael Whitney
and grace got on one of those planes and
are finally back in Georgia it feels
great
believe how big our boys have gotten a
family once separated by continents now
finally together as one for CBS this
morning Saturday Kris Van Cleave
Washington hard to imagine the
frustration when all you want to do is
be home